[Musique]
nous protégeons la terre de la vermine
de l'univers parmi nos agents déployés
dans toutes les grandes villes du monde
certains se sont plus illustre est que
d'autres
agent tâche vous êtes l'un des meilleurs
à avoir porté le costume ou
mais vous avez besoin d'un équipier
ça fait du bien et elle touche les men
in black
nous avons ré problème à londres agent m
allez on y va
le monde se sauvera pas tout seul tiers
connect a besoin de moi pour sauver le
monde bien sûr
[Musique]
on fait un rapport rapport non la
paperasse c'est un vrai cauchemar
d'où notre viseur
là vous pourriez regarder pas essayer
ces bons démarre
marc on va bien se marrer
il doit y avoir un gros bouton rouge
quelque part j'ai trouvé en direct la
chance vient de la saison là franchement
tu m'as précieux